casque sur la tête julie produits
dumortier qui va servir à la rénovation
de ce rempart 7 nivernaise réalise ce
stage bénévoles dans le cadre de ses
études d'architecte
une expérience qu'elle juge utiles pour
son avenir professionnel
là on apprend à choisir les bonnes
pierre utilisait le mortier comme il
faut et donc notamment les outils qui
sont utiles et c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant pour voir comment est ce que
les ouvriers travaillent en tant que
futur peut-être architecte c'est assez
important
soula fait marié aime appeler que le
mortier autour des pierres nettoyer
étudiante en première année à l'école
nationale d'architecturé de marrakech
elle profite de cette première
expérience à l'étranger
pour en apprendre plus sur notre
patrimoine j'ai passionné par la
restauration du patrimoine qu'il soit
français aux marocains donc le fait
qu'ils soient français
ça va nous élargir nos connaissances
comme elle ils sont onze bénévoles à
s'impliquer dans ce chantier
participatif de rénovation des remparts
un véritable partage d'expérience et une
ouverture sur le monde pour marième on a
la chance de voir comment on peut vivre
dans une communauté de gens qui sont
différents de croyances des
personnalités de principe mais en fait
quand même créer quelque chose de boké
sur en bas en six ans l'association vie
et patrimoine a permis la réhabilitation
de plusieurs mètres de remparts a reçu
de vézelay mais selon sa présidente
il reste encore près de 1200 mètres de
mur à restaurer nous ne vivons que de
dons et surtout de subventions de la
région la mairie de tout ce qui est
public de la drac en particulier et
c'est très difficile tandis que si on
intègre dans le grand site line et des
moyens considérables et c'est l'état qui
prend 80 % les dépenses à l'avenir
l'association espère donc faire intégrer
la réhabilitation des remparts dans le
projet grand site de vézelay un projet
qui a permis notamment la rénovation de
la porte neuve ou encore de la basilique
grâce au fonds de l'état et de l'europe